[Music]
you better be gone
hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to the return to bloody
nights we return to the return to blood
that's dumb I can only describe my
success in the last episode as by the
skin of my teeth and teeth doesn't have
skin so it was really really close if
they introduce another animatronic in
Friday I'm probably boned I don't
actually know how close I was to death
but I can only assume that I was really
really close because my God I was just
panicking the entire time so if they
introduce another animatronic on Friday
I'm boned I am going to express my
condolences
he told you about the safety thank you
Henry
without a doubt this is a tragedy oh
I'm sorry William
if there's anything I can do
it's too late for that
it's too late for everything
I know
I've lost people too
I know what it feels like to feel that
the world is coming to an end
no you don't
you have no idea what it's like to lose
a child
you have a perfect life your happy
family you don't know anything
you don't know how I feel right now
I'm sorry William I just enough
you can't even imagine what's happening
to me right now
I understand that you're going through a
difficult time William but please don't
do anything rash think of the safety it
won't solve anything be safe Henry
won't solve anything
but I'm not interested in solving
anything
I'm interested in
Revenge oh no
that doesn't sound safe
you have it all don't you Henry
a happy family
a fulfilling life
and yet
faint strikes without warning
William
I know
I'm truly sorry about what happened
is there anything I can do to help
no
there's nothing you or anyone can do
but there are things that must be done
what things William
that's not for you to worry about Henry
just remember this
every action
as a consequence
and some consequences
are more dire
than others
well a lot of consequences can be
averted by properly thinking about
safety it's that damn cupcake I knew I
saw something
yesterday in the left cam by the door
there definitely were well I'm gonna die
because I'm not even gonna be able to
listen good job back five
um
hey um
tonight okay tonight I just finished
checking the CCTV camera for
refused to be in order
ly now now listen I know things have
been a bit strange lately the building
and the other restaurants are closed and
the police are still investigating The
Disappearance of around six children
it's a serious matter and we're doing
everything we can to help the
authorities yet for some reason police
seem to think we're covering up evidence
well let me tell you something that's
not possible unless someone from our
company is involved and I can assure you
involved in any way
for Christ's sake one of those children
belongs to one of the founders of this
place
the poor kid disappeared about a month
ago it breaks my heart to think about it
we will get to the bottom of this though
whoever is Behind These incidents will
pay if something bad happened to those
kids and for the damage they've done to
our company's reputation you can count
on that
in the meantime keep up the good work
thanks animatronics and let's finish
this week strong
is all over mark my words we'll take
this company to new heights New Heights
dedicated
to our Future's looking bright my friend
anyway I gotta run to the cinema to
catch electric eel2 the slithering
the first one you know
all right good luck tonight and I'll see
you bright and early tomorrow
thank you
thank you enjoy the movie I guess oh
this is gonna be a problem everybody
whoa that's not good
oh God wait no hold on wait go away
right so
uh well no need to bees
all right
good stuff
great stuff actually
don't know why I thought that was
definitely someone there but there
wasn't I was all alone
man this is horrible
[Music]
I don't know why that puppet sounds like
footsteps every time it moves
[Music]
yeah well I thought I thought that's
what I get for thinking
oh
terrible horrible horrible and terrible
don't like it bad vibes
if I get Bap Vibes I don't even care
oh
foreign
wait what
what was that
what just happened did I press on
something
oh
nah
it's gonna go with a big no on that one
see I don't know what the cupcake does I
do there's so much going on that I don't
even know if I have a chance to survive
at anything
or epic oh sweet
I'm gonna make it this is going great
oh man oh I didn't think that I didn't
think anyone would be there
again don't know what the cupcake's all
about but
[Music]
you're still there
I don't like that
oh you should have made some noise
I'm in trouble oh God I'm in trouble I'm
in trouble oh crap
oh crap I'm in trouble
okay
you better be gone
be patient before opening or you'll meet
defeat that makes so much sense now ah
well I was in a bit of a hurry because I
got in trouble
shut up I don't care about your weird
animatronic legs or whatever the hell
you were jabbering on about no one cares
I'm just here to get my massive paycheck
and get out
okay peek-a-boo bunny is on the way
oh you're still there you you just stay
there for such a long time so peekaboo
bunny is over there oh I heard a dog
never mind
you're still okay
oh my God
okay I heard that come on
[Music]
Frick I knew it God okay so when
peek-a-boo bunny is even closer there it
doesn't matter shouldn't even do that
shouldn't let peekaboo bunny get that
close what is this what's this boob
thing that was my fault that was my bad
I should have known but I didn't do it
it's my fault and it's okay
we all make mistakes
we all learn
we all grow as a human being as an
individual we all grow
so when peekaboo Bunny Gets about to
right here that's when it's bad
Alexian decipher it lyxian capture
record it you recorded it
did you get all that
good decipher it and tell me all the
secrets
creeps
craves all right
[Music]
foreign
you just bypass it
bubani I saw him
was both of them
whoa how did I do a fast
I did like a super fast move
that was great
I wish I could do that at whoop bunny
nope not playing
but I didn't mean to go back
my mouse is in the was that me
oh
so the boob was my boob but I didn't
look bad I wasn't even looking back my
mouse was in the middle I didn't even go
to the ride
that's what dank clearly it's the game
that's wrong and not me
clearly
[Music]
oh frick well that's gonna
oh frick my God move your ass
I'm dead
no I'm a dead man
what oh cool
uh well this is a problem
gonna be fine
because I'm gonna do this
perfect I'm the best of the best ever
oh wow that's oh I'm doomed oh I'm
doomed oh I'm running it
[Music]
I'm doing it God I'm the best ever
good Lord oh God
hey don't point at me when I'm dead for
breathing light what is breathing light
mean listen close for breathing light I
think the answer all this guide is that
I need to not be bad and I've been
playing like I was bad I got really
close on the first try there I don't
know what happened to me
I don't know what happened to me I
really wish the camera was on a uh
button press
and not necessarily
a uh and not on a mouse flick
but that is the Five Nights at Freddy's
way I know that's how it's always been
so that's how it will be add infinitum
oh
I just need to steal what time I can
with them open because they're just
gonna be times where it's going to be
bad why are you not there God
oh you really need to be oh
but I'm still not there
oh God no Frick no Frick no Frick no
frick I'm dead frick frick frick frick
frick frick frick
it's fine
it turns out it wasn't fine
oh power oh power oh God
hurry up
on the right hurry up thank you good
oh God no
come on
do it I dare you to do it oh God
[Music]
hurry up squonker
squonker
can't be serious
oh God
but you were gone
oh
oh my God
I would love also a little arrow box
when I hit the bottom Edge when I'm at
the back because I can't quite tell
what's happening all the time
and it makes it a little inconvenient I
still don't know what the cupcake does
but I know it's gonna be a lot of
that's what I know about it I didn't
spring that
oh boy here we go
you know what
when it does the that's when it's
actually there
holy crap
foreign
oh I'm in trouble aren't I
oh God I'm in trouble she's waiting for
you what she wants to play what
what are you talking about
what was that
[Music]
wait no
oh man God damn it
all right one more go I got this I think
I got it if I get this one more time I
was very close and it's just a rhythm
it's basically a rhythm game if you
think about it also who's waiting for me
to play what huh that was weird
yeah there are more times when I can
wait for the actually and we're trying
to be at the door and instead of just uh
almost at the door because that's what
gets me is just like leaving the doors
closed like that for sure I mean given
that it's the only way that you can even
generate heat in the first place yeah of
course it's I mean
I'm an idiot if I just have to spell
that out and people don't get that then
that's their fault but I'm an idiot so I
have to spell that out
so like that that's threatening but it's
not necessarily meaning that he's right
there
[Music]
oh God
heard that
and that's how you do it
how much longer
Oh weird okay there we go
that's handled
[Music]
it's a problem
it's a bad place to be
but here I am
it's a bad place to be but here I am
don't know why
oh God can we get that ah needle need to
let it cool back down I can't let myself
get caught in that way again
[Music]
I just get sandwiched in between
that's no good Freddie's coming down
left
Freddy and Bonnie both
what are you doing there
Bonnie's coming over there
holy
was that
I heard two
holy
oh God
where are you
oh all right we got peekaboo man what
nope peek-a-boo man all right he's
almost here
he's not here yet I gotta check this so
I can make sure he's not here
[Music]
I'm gonna go ahead and do it
wasn't even close was he
[Music]
okay he's over there
you're there
get you
you can take the Heat
both of those guys
[Music]
done easy not easy
okay
got this handled
for the most part
I don't know how close I've ever been to
this puppet getting me
but I really hope not close
it's part of that thing where I kind of
want to know how close I am to death but
at the same time not really
I could do without knowing you're not
alone
so I'm on a security camera of course
I've been watching you guys
all right
oh God I really did that one early on
the left on the right there
I can take the heat I can take the Heat
and closed in
oh yes
yes easy
smooth smooth as baby butt
what do I get
do I get my paycheck it has been many
years since the incident that changed
everything oh for the lack of safety I
have done unforgivable things since then
so unsafe the missing children
it was all my doing what but do not
mistake my confidence for remorse for I
am not sorry
my animatronics were always meant to be
more than mere entertainers huh
they were created to wield fear
to evoke Terror
and bring forth the ultimate consequence
death
so they're meant to kill Elizabeth
my sweet Elizabeth
you failed to listen to me
she became the unfortunate victim of a
programming error
a mere flaw in my creation just a simple
little flaw but I could not bear the
burden of responsibility
for that would tarnish my Flawless image
instead
I pushed the blame away onto others
for I could not admit a fault
and then there was Charlotte
Henry's daughter
I could not bear to see him basking all
his happiness
and receive all the credit for our work
my jealousy consumed me
and I had to take matters into my own
hands
do not think for a moment that I fear
the consequences of my actions
I am not guilty
not in my mind
I meticulously crafted the evidence to
make it appear
as though Henry was the one responsible
for I had bigger plans in mind
plans that require my full attention and
dedication
I have built a new place for my New
Creations
place that will instill wonder and fear
Into the Heart of all who bear Witness
and soon
I will reveal what is coming next
all right
um nothing that you said made sense but
hey love sister location that's pretty
cool that's pretty cool right there
that's
that's pretty cool but it seems like you
were a shitty person even before you
killed your daughter and making
animatronics that were meant to deal the
ultimate consequence of death which is a
really roundabout way to say that they
were their big old murder Bots which is
what they are if that is as simple as
you want to be
how are you that was good I really liked
it it it got a bit frantic there and
there wasn't a lot of explanation but
I'm fine with that I figure it out as I
go along I think that the uh UI could
have used a few tweaks to make it a
little easier but I got through it just
fine and there's still a sixth night and
a custom night so if you would like me
to play those please let me know down in
the comments below because we got payday
and we got custom night and we got none
of these
and we got
this guy and that guy great stuff I
really like that thumbs up but if you
guys want to see more there is more to
do Saturday and custom night I do not
guarantee I will ever do a 20 mode if
there is one in this I've
I've retired I've uh hung up my crown
I'm uh definitely you know I don't do
that anymore so if you want to see it
don't even bother asking in the comments
below for me to do it I would I would
never
so thank you and as always I will see
you in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]
foreign